if you have good notes and you have very very thoroughly mapped out a target and you've captured
all this information you can do this with little to no overhead in your current bug bounty flow
best part of hacking when you can just you know critical thing
all right hackers the ad read is going to get a little technical today so buckle up for this okay
i'm going to tell you exactly how threat locker is screwing hackers at every step along the way
with dynamic access controls preventing even port scans from happening on threat locker networks so
uh let's dive into it there's three primary ways that threat locker implements this i'm going to give
you guys two for this for this quick read um and hopefully you'll be able to understand how exactly
they're preventing hackers from doing port scans um so first one is called local challenge this is on
the common scenario where a computer wants to connect to a network resource and they're on the same network
so what's going to happen is over you know this this threat locker handshake uh the computer is going
to send a request to the server the server is going to respond with a challenge and then uh the computer
has to you know complete that challenge and provide a response back to the server before the smb port is
even opened up to that specific computer right so you can't do any port scanning or anything like that
because you're not going through this handshake with the computer um so that's that's one way the next
way is in like remote work scenarios where your laptop is like you know out on some wi-fi or whatever
and you still need to access network resources um in this scenario the computer is going to shoot an i
you know authenticated ip change up to the threat locker cloud then when it requests access to a
specific server maybe it's trying to get in by like rds or whatever if it's if it's uh in a remote work
scenario the rds server you know before it opens up that port is going to query the allow list in the
threat locker cloud and say hey uh this ip is trying to connect what should i do with him um and then
threat locker cloud will give them a yes or no on that and they'll open or close the port based on
that response okay so with threat locker in place really you can't even do port scans guys so tell
you what let's go back to the show and hack something easier and we'll let threat locker do their thing
all right all right let's go all right hackers i've got an awesome article in the this weekend bug bounty
segment for you okay this is yes we hacks minefield between syntaxes exploiting syntax confusions in the wild
and i learned so much from this just reading over this article okay so typically on in this segment
i'm just going to give you articles to go read and give you a summary of them this time we're actually
going to dive in a little bit okay so let's check this out this article is focused on syntax confusion
which is essentially just weird ways to um represent syntax in various contexts and the research here is
lovely okay the first one blew my freaking mind look at this okay what is this c code how does this work
okay apparently there are these things called trigraphs and digraphs in c's or in c which is um
character sequences such as question mark question mark equal sign or um percent sign colon or
uh less than percent sign and these just are converted by the compiler into different characters
on the fly so this c code right here which uh i'm sorry for those of you listening but this c code here
that just has no curly brackets at all and just uses less than sign a percent sign compiles totally fine
and runs crazy absolutely crazy so look up see digraphs and trigraphs um less than percent sign is
equal to the left curly bracket or the open curly bracket it's like how does this even exist these are
the things that hackers need to know so that we can do cool syntax bypasses okay so that was the first one
um the next one was uh parsing on specific ports right like you can uh pad your zeros uh your port number
with zeros and a url right so 000443 right same thing as 443 um oh this one was really interesting
apparently in python you can reference specific characters unicode characters using their backslash
capital n syntax so backslash capital n greek capital letter delta in all caps it will give you the
actual character point for that like what is this backslash capital n with curly brackets syntax in in python
and pearl is super weird um and apparently there's a backslash p curly brackets um syntax as well
that is just whack um oh okay and then check this one out guys in in um you guys have seen content
disposition all the time in your uh multi-part form um http request right apparently there's another format
for this right where it's not just file name equals my file.txt you can do file name equals uh asterisk
equals and then specify like a character set like utf-8 and then provide that um file name okay so now we
can smuggle in unicode characters into our file names in content disposition uh on multi-part form http
requests okay which is going to be awesome for unicode normalization um so good okay so anyway this article
by yes we hack is phenomenal it's chock full of these sort of syntax confusions and real life uh bug bounty
finds right like um that he does a full read ssrf uh and uh a cache poisoning bug so uh go ahead and check
out this write-up we'll link it in the description the minefield between syntax is exploiting the syntax
confusions in the wild and check out those like c trigraphs and digraphs and the backslash capital n
syntax to access unicode code points in python and pearl all right uh let's get to the main content i
think brandon is doing an episode today by himself which is awesome he's gonna rock it um pay close
attention to this okay because taking notes in bug bounty is extremely extremely extremely important um
and brandon is the go-to hacker in my opinion that does this extremely well so lots of good content
here enjoy y'all hello everyone it's brandon brett me we've got a bit of a different episode uh today
for you it's going to be shorter as it's a solo episode but it covers one of the topics i've
personally had a lot of questions on and has led to a lot of success for me personally as a bug hunter
and that's how to have long-term success on the target and my note-taking methodology for that
now for full transparency this is also coming from a hunter who is most definitely not a recon guy
that's not me it never has been so long-term success on the target really boils down to my
note-taking my javascript monitoring my general target monitoring outside of javascript monitoring and
also collabing we'll start off with the notes as it feeds into everything else i do on my approach
but hopefully it makes sense so for the audio listeners i will be sharing my screen but i'll do
my absolute best to talk through it as well
okay so my notes essentially starts off with a default template every time i personally use notion i'm pretty
much embedded into notion um but you can use whatever you like as long as you capture all this information
i don't really think it matters too much so my default template first consists of the target
the target's tech stack and what i'm looking at here is really the frameworks and the languages in use
any third-party components in use whether that's certain libraries for billing javascript widgets things
like that um if it has any reliance on other applications what database it uses and all those kinds of things
that's the first part of the notes and what opens up the target then after that uh the brainstorming
slash risk section now this is essentially where i threat model and this is also the area where you're
going to want to put down every single attack vector you can possibly think of and everything that you've
tried um so for example i've got a little note here for myself to threat model and highlight high risk
areas to target first and then walk through that and how i actually take these notes is i have
the end point or the functionality i have a bullet point for the information i um that i captured from
that and i also have a little tick box for the actual check that i want to do now the idea here is
that you put down all your checks but i'll come back onto this later on now i also have a high signal
area and this is an area where if you're hunting for a long time on the target and you've identified a
really high signal search whether that be a google doc um a very high signal grep for example in javascript
files or just kind of how they identify their roots whether that be api client side whatever it might be
that goes down to my high signal section and what that allows me to do is whenever i'm looking for
something quick um i can just quickly come back to here and and search for that and see it straight
away on the target the other thing as well i have an error oracle section and i don't really hear too much
talk about this although i see a lot of hunters inadvertently doing this and tracking them and an
error oracle is essentially a a part of the application or an endpoint that you can use to intentionally force an
error to disclose information about the target the system the application the process whatever you're
looking at so say for example you have identified that there's a very very sketchy endpoint that when
you instead of putting in i don't know a url starting with http you put in a url starting with
or uri starting with ftp and it causes it to fall over it gives you the internal host in use it
discloses some ports maybe even some authentication headers put that down in your error oracle the reason i
have a section for error oracles is because there has been more times than i can count where i have
disclosed a bunch of information whether that's through a verbose error um whether that's through
just general fuzzing whatever it might be and it hasn't ever been useful to me at that time it's good
information to have but it wasn't useful to me i couldn't exploit it put that down in your oracle
section in your notes and i can pretty much guarantee you if you hunt on the target for a long time that
will come in useful one example of this is i was in a live event in i think it was in april and i
had an error oracle where i could disclose a ton of information about an internal service in use
including internal host names authentication headers ports everything a lot of information i noted it down
wasn't useful maybe last month or the month before that information actually came in useful when i was
building out an attack chain on a similar but different area of the target so definitely note those down
they are invaluable especially when you're hunting long term on the target and then the last part is
attack paths and gadgets and this sort of feeds into the other two but if i'm building out an attack path
um or i have a bunch of gadgets whether that would be clients like path traversal open redirect
um a quirk in there or flow things like that i note them all down here and even if it's semi-built out
attack chains they still go down they still come in useful and i also have a tracker at the bottom
and if i am actively working on multiple um attack chains or multiple bugs which uh convoluted and i
can't get done in one session they'll go down into my tracker at the bottom so i'll show you what this
looks like on an old target and this is an older version from a target maybe last year that i was looking
at and i've noted everything down here so first of all it starts off with all of the scope and credentials
for example um then we've got the behavior now this is very very nice information to capture if you
look at a target for a couple of months don't look at it and come back to it this is sort of information
that will let you look at your notes and hit the ground running so i've got release notes for the target
i've got support documentation for the target i've got documentation on their access controls if they
have weekly demos and webinars on new functionality uh documentation on their user and auth matrix all of
that is captured so i can come back save it refer to it at a later date also have the behavior of what
the target does um information on the tech stack the user levels framework and language um then fill
that's third party components here for whatever reason now this here is for me what makes me effective i
think as a hunter because i threat model and i threat model a lot on targets and every single thing i can
think of whether that's um related to i don't know basic idle testing xss more exotic authentication bugs um
everything and i mean everything goes down in here so for example the first point here is i've got
cookies signed using rails but can be removed um with a screenshot as well which i've toggled so you
can't see it um and all all of these checks so email functionality export import account functionality
and the checks i've done i've ticked off for example here error of course 500 when important html file
now i'm showing you a redacted version obviously because i can't disclose too much information but
this allows me to list all my attack vectors and for everyone watching this it's just
genuinely and i'm like massive massive page of all of these different attack vectors all of my different
notes what works what didn't work um so i can keep track of the target and thoroughly assess each
piece of functionality and be sure that i have thoroughly assessed it now the idea here is that
these notes are a living breathing document you don't ever really want to complete them you want
to list down as many attack vectors as you can possibly find whether that's from new research you've had
whether that is if the targets release new functionality whether whatever it might be
this is a living breathing document that you always append to and always keep notes of now the
good thing is when you get to a certain threshold in your notes and you have a lot of information about
the target this enables you to really effectively collab with someone and what i mean by this is
if you feel like you have absolutely kicked the living daylights out of a target and you feel like
that you can't push it any further at least for now until a couple of months time you can pass these
notes to another hacker and they can just hit the ground running see what works get some immediate
feedback get some immediate gadgets get a feel for the target within i don't know how long would this
take to read maybe 10 minutes to get to thoroughly read them and they can just go
and get hunting now there isn't a recent example i can think of this and i hope they don't mind me
shouting them out but green jam and j rock have been collabing a lot and sharing notes on a target that
they both look at pretty heavily and they have absolutely cleaned the floor just by sharing notes
and sharing gadgets on things that they both looked at but maybe couldn't exploit at the time
and it's been a bit of a bloodbath so very very useful um which is why it's one of my big things on a
long-term target now the other thing is as well javascript monitoring um i'm not gonna
get into the weeds of what tools to use what frameworks to use and things like that i'm just
going to tell you some very high signal things i monitor for which does let you identify if there's
been a new change on the target and you obviously want to be the first one to look at that so
first of all you want to and let me just go back for a second if you have good notes and you have very
very thoroughly mapped out a target and you've captured all this information you can do this with
little to no overhead in your current bug bounty flow say for example you've mapped out exactly how
their endpoints their roots their permission sets are mapped out in javascript and you have that in
your high signal search area of your notes you can do all this very quickly it'll just be a case of
spinning up a server identifying creating a few regexes maybe and setting up that monitoring you'll be
completely good to go which is why i'm so keen on having really good notes but anyway the things i look
for are request handlers endpoint declarations user permissions user flags and content types now i have
this as a template to remind myself of things to look for because i can fall into a bit of a
bit of a hole when i'm hunting and just forget to do certain things so having my notes is very
essential and if you've collapsed with me or worked with me like justin will know this if i need to do
something and it isn't written down on chance i'm never ever going to do it so anyway i have things
like uh orphan session flows which i look at which is uses of things like local storage session storage
post message um i monitor new endpoints associated with the password reset and password recovery flows if
there are one another big one as well is privilege and feature controls so you might look at it and
every target is obviously going to be different but there might be cases where you will see a lot of
strings in javascripts to show you client-side routes and different permissions with things like
is staff is internal entitlements scopes is admin is user is all these different sort of roles
if you can identify exactly how these are defined throughout an app and monitor them you can pretty
much be sure that if you get a new hit on one of these there's going to be a new user role or new
functionality coming out which probably hasn't been looked at if you're quick enough and that's going
to be very high signal for you i've had a lot of success personally identifying these different roles
and making sure i'm monitoring for them another thing as well is feature flags and justin talks a lot about
this in his um in some of his previous talks around uh response like rewriting and things like that
if you can identify new feature flags for a b testing again you can just pretty much unlock
most times new functionality a new attack surface um obviously you've got your endpoint discovery as
well you want to look at how these are identified and one thing here is i've noticed with a lot of
standard monitoring i've looked at there's a lot of focus around naturally hdcps urls but you also have
web sockets and that's very target specific so if you can set up monitoring for that as well
that could be very high signal graphql you've got method and verbs you also have
query um parameters and depending on how they're defined on the target you'll get different return
on investment there now other things i have more recently started monitoring for as well which i
touched upon earlier is client-side syncs um before my monitoring was heavily focused around endpoints
and roles and um feature flags and things like that but that can also be quite high signal if you're
monitoring javascript um and you set it up you might as well do the extra extra overhead as well to to
look at the other things um what else have we got and i've just got a few other high signal things i
try to look for file and content handling service workers um framework specific hot spots this is a good
one if you have like an xjs target for example if you're they're using graphql there's going to be
patterns you can lock into on those targets which will be very high signal and allow you to harvest
things a lot more easier um and yeah i've given myself some handy reject snippets and examples just to
remind myself and quickly set up javascript monitoring and the whole point of this and the
whole point of the notes is to have very high signal very frictionless things that you can do to add to your
your hunting uh processes which give you a pretty much immediate or close to immediate roi which
is as less overhead as possible to to implement so that's kind of what it looks like and
the important thing to note here as well let's just go into here okay this is an example of a
of another application that i set up to demo if you have a target which for example is more of an
ecosystem than a single app and there's multiple apis or if it's a startup scope for example i just
personally create another page in here and i start the process all over again i create a page per
application or page per api and go through that process again you start off with your endpoint or your
functionality you have your bullet point to capture the information on that what it does then you have
your check on the actual check to perform so test for in the idle in the idle parameter i wish there's an
idle parameter in the id parameter as it's reflected and then once you complete this check you go back up
here and then you add your feedback from that check and say not possible escaped properly in id parameter
and yeah that's sort of how i map that out in my flow as i said the idea here is that you capture all
this information and you want to go in with the mindset of okay this is for long-term success where you
want to capture the high signal things which might not be useful in that current moment you're hunting
but later on down the line it most definitely is and for me the the thing when this really clicked and
made sense was my first month in hunting i started in january this year full-time and obviously it's quite
daunting when you start hunting the very first thing i've done i went through all my notes for all my regular
targets about four or five targets i regularly look at and my entire first month and i'm being 100
serious here was pretty much bred from my notes and things that i noted down wasn't useful to me at
the time i come back with a fresh set of eyes or there's been new functionality or if i'd found new
gadgets on that target later on down the line which i had also noted down and i could basically just
chain them together carry on hunting and that was pretty much my first month i'd done that also went
through my old bug reports and bypass them so perhaps you don't have notes right now um i will be
releasing my templates that i use these are my strips down ones for people to use and apply universally
across targets so they can cater towards whatever they're looking at i use notion they'll probably be
releasing the hacker notes and if you're just getting started my flow on how i do this personally
i'll sit down on the target for a couple of hours i'll go through i'll map out the application
just take my initial notes from there and then say every i don't know at the end of every day after
that point i'll note down my attack vectors check my proxy log check my burp history check my kardo history
go for all that and note down the things that did work didn't work my error oracles my high signal
searches all the gadgets i found from that day on now if you want a bit of a cheat code to get started
if you don't do this already start by going through your old reports on a target noting down everything
that you did find bugs in how you found them the endpoints are found in the parameters are found in
the bug type if there were any error or of course identified in that and start off with that
you might be able to start bypassing all fixes and things so what this does it might not be the
sexiest method to get started off in but it does definitely allow you to capture a lot of information
to come back to that information at a later date and hit a target hard now as i said earlier if you can
capture all that and give this to another hunter and let's say for example you are looking to collab and
you're not sure who to collab with contact one of the top 20 top 15 top 10 hunters on the program you're
looking at ask if they want to collab build that trust and maybe start sharing your notes and i can
guarantee that if you've captured them in this level in this format you will be able to start sharing
notes collabing and getting more information so i hope you find it useful the templates on all of this
on my notes on basic javascript monitoring the things i captured exactly what you're looking at here
will be cap um will be shared with you on i'm guessing it's going to be the hacker notes
and you can clone this in notion if you don't use notion just use a similar layout to whatever your
favorite note taking is and it will work i hope you find it useful i've had a lot of questions on this
i haven't really shown it in this much depth before and again it's not the sexiest but it will most
definitely allow you to capture a lot of information which will lead to longer term success on a target
and allow you to essentially get free bugs when you have enough information captured and you revisit
a target at a later date it's worked for me i've shown a few hunters that i've had good feedback
overall on it i've given some hunters i've collabed with my notes and it's allowed them to hit the ground
running and start hunting very quickly so i hope you find it useful as i said bit of a different episode
today a bit of a shorter episode as well but this might be useful to some of you so let me know what
you think i'll be sharing them and yeah thank you everyone and that's a wrap on this episode
of critical thinking thanks so much for watching to the end y'all if you want more critical thinking
content uh or if you want to support the show head over to ctbb.show discord you can hop in the
community there's lots of great high level hacking discussion happening there on top of master classes
hack alongs exclusive content and a full-time hunters guild if you're a full-time hunter it's a great
time trust me i'll see you there